welcome to Hannity we begin tonight this
busy Friday news night with the Fox News
Alert tonight we are witnessing what
will be a massive paradigm shift in the
future of Disease Control and Prevention
a bold new precedent is being set the
world will once again benefit greatly
from America's leadership will give us
reason to be proud as a country the
federal government state governments
private businesses top hospitals all
coming together under the president's
leadership to stem the tide of the
coronavirus now the announcement came
earlier today in the Rose Garden the
president declared a national emergency
freeing up up to fifty billion dollars
in new funding now that new funding will
be crucial to what is a major
groundbreaking public/private
partnership all designed to protect the
health the well-being of the American
family our family that means your loved
ones everybody take a look to unleash
the full power of the federal government
of this effort today I am officially
declaring a national emergency two very
big words the action I am taking will
open up access to up to fifty billion
dollars today we are announcing a new
partnership with private sector to
vastly increase and accelerate our
capacity to test for the coronavirus we
want to make sure that those who need a
test can get a test very safely quickly
and conveniently we've been in
discussions with pharmacies and
retailers to make drive-through tests
available in the critical locations
identified by public health
professionals what happened today gone
is the old way of thinking government
walls itself off tries to solve problems
all on its own and now thanks to really
a deal maker in chief an entrepreneur
lifelong businessman in the White House
there is now a new way to solve crisis
that has been developed and is unfolding
before our very eyes you're witnessing
history in the making and with the help
of the most amazing companies in this
country private sector companies the
administration is now created what will
be the most robust plan never tried
before to battle the core
virus across all 50 states today we
heard from representatives from several
major companies involved America's
biggest and best corporations by the way
they deserve to be praised tonight look
at your screen Walmart alphabet aka
Google Walgreens Target CVS quest
Diagnostics L AC group Becton Dickinson
Roche signify health
LabCorp are all playing a role here now
here's what you need to know with the
help of Google's parent company a brand
new website is being developed where
Americans can go to determine if and
when and where they should go to get a
test for coronavirus 1700 Google
professionals working on that new
drive-through test sites are now in the
works all across the country this will
drastically reduce the spread of this
virus and future viruses hospitals
frankly are in many cases where many
people become infected when fully up and
running this will also take much-needed
pressure off of hospitals and leave beds
open to know those that are most in need
in the coming days they'll be setting up
in parking lots of big box Realtors like
Walmart Target and other big stores and
meanwhile US drug and testing companies
have now developed a rapid new way to
test for the corona virus and according
to officials results from the new test
kits should take around 24 hours with
just one stroke of a pen all of the
bureaucracy all of the weeks all of the
testing all the approvals happened in
hours of course this is only but one
facet of the president's public-private
partnership the administration has
developed similar relationships with
hospitals and universities and insurance
companies and American banks all in an
effort to keep you safe and combat this
pandemic and get our economy back on
track this is frankly America at its
best these are the doctors the medical
researchers the scientists the
entrepreneurs rising to the occasion as
great Patriots in a crisis these are the
people I've been telling you about for
weeks that I put the most faith in none
of these companies had to partner with
the administration they didn't have to
do it they did it because they love the
country they care about their fellow
Americans and they're committed to
saving
this frankly what we saw today can only
happen in this great country of America
this is free-market capitalism at its
best how many of these companies by the
way have you heard demonized over the
years Oh big pharmaceutical companies
all the Walmarts of the world Wow maybe
they deserve a pat on the back today
made possible by the president leading
the way well we all need to understand
tonight is all of this did not happen in
one day it did not happen overnight as
one official put it this has been in the
works behind the scenes for quite some
time outside the view of the media mob
and of course the general public because
there was no guarantee this would all
come together the way it has take a look
I understand that a lot of this
behind-the-scenes action over the last
couple of weeks was invisible to the
press and the American people but this
intense effort has not only resulted in
innovative solutions but an automated
high throughput system bringing the
availability of these quality Korona
viral testing to the American people at
unprecedented speed now ultimately all
of this work covers three very important
areas testing treatment economic
recovery and the implementation is well
underway for more context let's go back
to the timeline this is very important
December 30th with the w-h-o they
discover an unknown virus with pneumonia
like symptoms that was first observed in
the Wuhan province area of China
January 7th the corona virus was first
identified that's of this year by
January 31st three weeks later the
President Trump administration declared
a public health emergency Americans
abroad within subject to mandatory
quarantines on military bases on
February 2nd the President ordered a
temporary travel ban for all non US
citizens who recently visited China in
the days that followed the president
formed a task force filled with the top
scientific medical professionals in the
country led by the vice president of the
United States February 29th that travel
ban was extended to Iran
on the same day the State Department
issued new travel restrictions to Italy
and South Korea also on the 29th the FDA
cut regulations allowing more rapid
testing more capacity for coronavirus
March 2nd president Trump met with
pharmaceutical executives these meetings
now will come into a broader picture
what was going on March the 3rd the
administration ordered the CDC to lift
all restrictions on testing March the
6th the president he signed an eight
point three billion dollar emergency
spending package into law on March the
10th the president met with insurance
industry representatives remember they
agreed to waive co-pays for Corona
related treatment on March the 11th he
met with banking and business executives
to discuss economic relief for those
businesses directly impacted by the
virus and hourly workers the same thing
on the same day he extended the travel
the temporary travel ban to all of
continental Europe these travel bans
were critically important why because it
prevented many other Americans from
getting infected or contracting this
virus
take a look our aggressive containment
strategy as it started early enough to
avoid that that peak that Italy well
experiencing as I mentioned there were
two components of that that's preventing
from without to in and there's what you
do mitigation in clearly early on we
made a travel ban with regard to China
that was a very smart move right there
because what that did was prevent a
major influx from China today the new
China is Europe by the way breaking just
moments ago President Trump just
announced his support for the
Congressional coronavirus relief package
we'll have more on that coming up
doctor foul Qi is exactly right but will
anyone in the media mob the Democratic
Party have they given the president any
credit for anything he has done not one
thing in February there it was quid pro
quo Joe other top Democrats president
implements the travel ban he's called
hysterical and xenophobic and neither
Biden or Bernie Sanders would have ever
enacted the ban and there
ragging about it even still today old
school old model bureaucrat swamp
thinking in fact for more perspective
let's take a look at the h1n1 pandemic
swine flu 2009-2010 yes the obama-biden
years this fast Freddy pandemic
worldwide particularly deadly to
children unlike corona which is more
deadly to older people in April of 2009
yes Obama and Biden years a few days
after the pandemic was detected in the
US Obama's HHS secretary declared a
health emergency freeing up some money
I'll give credit that was a good move by
October of 2009 well more than 20,000
Americans had been hospitalized and more
than 1,000 American citizens were dead
1,000 and only then six months later
that then President Obama finally
declare a national emergency that year
the CDC estimated 60 point eight million
Americans were infected which ultimately
resulted in over 274,000 Americans being
hospitalized and nearly 13,000 Americans
at a one year period dying worldwide
about 500 upwards of five hundred and
seventy five thousand people died in
2009 from swine flu h1n1 the obama-biden
administration or as joe says the Oh
Biden Bhama administration they never
enacted a travel ban not once during the
h1n1 pandemic there were no quarantine
they weren't quick to act declare an
emergency a thousand Americans were dead
and by the way others were infected now
the media Mob how did they react back
then do you think they were going as
hard as they are against Obama and Biden
as they've been going after Trump and
they did next to nothing if you want to
know how corrupt the media mob in this
country is you should be disgusted by
what I'm about to show you this was
after 1,000 Americans were dead
tens of thousands had contracted the
disease oh then he decides to declare a
national emergency great timing now
let's watch the media coverage let's
talk about this is something that is
concerning a whole lot of people these
days we're talking about the age
one and one and now the president
President Barack Obama declaring the
swine flu outbreak a national emergency
should there be a worst-case scenario
but administration officials are
emphasizing here fredericka it's not
that they are expecting one more than a
thousand people in the US have died from
the h1n1 virus 90 in the last week the
federal government had predicted there
would be a hundred million doses of
vaccine by now but as of this weekend
about 11 million were available when we
hear emergency alarm bells start to go
off what exactly does this declaration
mean well the first thing to say is
people shouldn't panic when they hear
this health officials battling the h1n1
flu virus this weekend have received two
booster shots of their own President
Obama has declared the virus of national
emergency notice a slight difference in
the coverage that is how corrupt the
media mob in this country has become in
ten short years that is disturbing what
they have done and what they are
currently doing is hurting our country
this defines them you ever had any doubt
that they have an agenda well that
proves our case never before has there
been this this unholy corrupt alliance
existing between the mob and the media
and the one party they love with their
agenda only the same people that have
been lying
hour after hour day after day week after
week month after month now for over
three years
Russia Russia Ukraine Ukraine and Peach
and Peach Corona Corona
that's how disgustingly corrupt they are
to the core it is repulsive
anybody that watches that video thousand
Americans dead no urgency it was like
nothing had happened
meanwhile President Trump he takes
unprecedented action within three weeks
travel ban quarantine what does he get
criticism you listen only to the mob and
the media might think that the President
may be cause the virus you begin to
think that I probably cooked it up in a
laboratory somewhere to destroy the
country likely with Putin and and Russia
and Ukrainian mad scientist's that
how distorted and conspiratorial and and
the level of hysteria and lying that's
gone on for three years
this alliance is hurting this country
they are not serving we the people in
any way shape matter or form they are
advancing a political agenda journalism
I declared in O seven is dead it is dead
it is done it is buried and it has now
become disgraceful state-run liberal
radical extreme socialist TV that's who
they are you would think the world is
coming to an end
listening to them this virus is serious
we've been telling you that from day one
we need to take the flu seriously we
need to take cancer seriously this virus
seriously of course we all need to
prepare accordingly and by the way this
is not pie in the sky tonight this will
be innovative this will allow future
presidents to have travel bans a lot
easier this will allow this time of
cooperation between the top companies in
this country to work hand in hand with
our government to keep us safe but you
do need to understand we will this is a
fact there are going to be dramatic
increases in the weeks ahead of the
number of Americans who test positive
and I doubt it they're gonna hike that
up I guarantee it that's what the mob
does and they'll blame Donald Trump
every second they can't acknowledge a
single good thing this president is done
they're against the travel ban
xenophobic racist they're against the
quarantine that alone sir saved
countless thousands of Americans from
contracting the virus that one decision
literally save thousands of Americans
from contracting this disease racist
xenophobic we expect at some point four
to six weeks according to all the
experts that I've been talking to
hopefully like in China there will be a
leveling off
that's where hopefully that will be
followed by a dramatic decrease and
reduction in new cases and hopefully
then back to normal life if you are
generally a healthy person under the age
of 80 and you don't have underlying
health issues or
a compromised immune system or getting
chemotherapy or autoimmune problems of
any kind
the odds of getting coronavirus and
dying are slim to none some people have
no symptoms some people have mild
symptoms some people will feel like it's
a flu or respiratory flu now but we got
to be careful for those people that are
sick and if you do know people that are
sick you got to keep a distance look out
for your friends and neighbors the basic
simple things we've been talking about
in the coming days and weeks as more
Americans get tested expect that sharp
rise it will be confirmed don't panic
ultimately we believe it will level off
we will begin a precipitous decline
let's hope we all can get back to normal